foreign
[Music]
welcome to Fight Night flashbacks I am
with a very special guest the UFC legend
himself former UFC heavyweight champion
this guy is on the Mount Rushmore of the
UFC it's my boy Frank bear the legend
what's up Legend a lot of people call
you Legend no not of any of those really
man I'd only if I had your career I'd
only have my kids refer to me as Legend
yeah I'm gonna tell the wife that tell
her when I walk in just call me Legend
now for this show we always look at some
like key moments in your fight career
you have so many so I I told my team I'm
gonna stay out of it because I'm such a
fan of yours I'm staying at it we're
going to end with a big nog for personal
reasons but um we're going to kick it
off with your very first fight in the
UFC with Roberto Tarvin and at this
you're 22. yeah 22 years old DFC and
this is before what year is this this
was 2001 November so Jesus Christ dude I
had two fights and professional shows
outside of this with no amateur career
and uh is the story didn't Joe Silva
have something to do with you yeah Joe
would come in it was funny so I'm
training at a place at the time called
modern martial arts in Las Vegas and uh
I had trained at a place called Nevada
partners for boxing and then I had a
buddy there goes you know a high school
friend of mine oh my older brother now
is is doing this Jiu Jitsu stuff you
know what I mean so I started going down
to there on training so I'd probably
been training for about two years in Jiu
Jitsu and then uh and obviously
interested mixed martial arts but at
that time there was no money in it yeah
it was more or less just another you
know Proving Ground something to do well
I just like to test myself I'm gonna go
out there and fight and learn okay and
people think that's weird but I'm like
dude guys do that all over the place 50
year old guys are entering Jiu Jitsu
tournaments or Tough Mudders and all
they're not getting paid to do that [ __ ]
and you do it to test yourself and so
that's really what I saw it as was an
opportunity to go out there and do that
and so Joe had came in on a 10 speed and
Parks his bike and comes in to watch his
train and goes yeah I'm the vice
president for the UFC and I'm looking
honest he's got five foot four times
on Joe Silva's time five four
coming into the gym talking about he's
the vice president for the UFC like did
you just come in on a 10 speed yeah
and not like you were on exercise he's
wearing jeans yeah it's all right so I
was like sure so he watched me roll
around he asked me hey you're interested
in fighting I'm like yeah very much so
you know I'm interested in it so I
actually gotten the two fights outside
of the UFC I think my first fight was in
Hook and shoot it was in uh
July and I fought again in like August
up in Northern California I think it was
a
IFC International fight Championship I
just remember it was like in a pentagon
on the guy there wasn't a lot going on
yeah and that was weird it was crazy
stuff and then uh and then uh
it was like on the path to wanting to be
in the UFC so I was living with my
Jujutsu coach at the time I just got my
purple belt and he comes and knocks on
my door he goes hey there was a falling
out you know the opponent got hurt some
guy was a silver medalist and blew his
knee out and he's supposed to fight
Roberto travin I'm like oh and the time
Roberto traveling was a four-time world
champion and Brazilian black belt you
know I'm like oh [ __ ] you know I had
thought I think he was 4-0 in the MMA
and so like you know he needs an
opponent 30 days notice you're a local
kid you you know they realize you're
taking a fight short notice and it's
kind of stacked against you but you know
you get the UFC contract I was like all
right well [ __ ] let's do it you know
what I mean 30 days let's go you know I
mean and I've always been you know I've
never said no to anything I like
challenges you know and so that's how
the opportunity came about Jesus Christ
yeah and Joe Silva he retired I think
once they sold in retired yeah 2012. I
think he lives in like Virginia or DC
yeah some super nice gym trains there oh
really yeah yeah if you ever talk to me
the whole downstairs of his house it's a
beautiful gym just trains and hangs out
reads comic books that makes sense still
doesn't drive though doesn't drive no no
a millionaire with no car hilarious he's
like oh cars break down people never I
think he's ever had a driver's license
he was a Savage man not somebody to
debate with if you're on the wrong side
I learned the hard way my my I remember
my manager was negotiating some fight
and you know I've always been like a
business guy I'm like I want to hear it
man they give me some tips to negotiate
he's like you don't want to hear the way
they talk about you guys I go no I'm
telling you and he was like I'm gonna
put him on speaker but don't say you're
here and you he did I I had tears in my
eyes like oh [ __ ] no I I got blessed I
should not have heard this throughout my
20s and you know early 30s Joe and I
would always you know go eat dinner
together hang out with you would Mentor
me on things and how he talked to you
when he thought you weren't there is how
he talked to me knowing I was there yeah
and with my wife chime in in two so yeah
there was something I gotta tell her hey
we're gonna eat dinner like a Xanax or
something yeah I'm like I mean it's like
you don't have to be that way yeah like
being the Matchmaker and dealing with
all these personalities had to be that
way before he started the fight is it
true that when you were in the UFC or
you you had to be in the FC at the time
you and Roy Nelson were the security
experiment Rhino yeah who the [ __ ] can
you imagine but I can't get out of here
I'm not going anywhere like security and
then you and Roy [ __ ] Nelson show up
that was true yeah oh really that's true
he actually worked a different shift
than I did because that would help his
training and stuff I work the night
shifts because you know I was the most
money and didn't really care about
getting good sleep so I mean up till uh
2008 I would work four nights a week
that's nuts work from you know 9 pm to 5
a.m I would take the week off before I
went to fight so even when I fought for
the UFC title when I fought uh Tim
Sylvia I literally worked up until
that's right nuts dude and then the week
before the fight took that weekend off
to try to get my sleep schedule fixed so
I wasn't such a you know uh yeah a night
owl yeah and then as soon as I would
fight I would next weekend I was back at
work and when you were a UFC champion
we're gonna swear I know yeah well I
mean I bet that wasn't fun at all yeah
okay let's see the fight I saved both
our marriage
go back we had time machine all right
let's see this fight man and this
fight's in Vegas
this fight in Vegas what uh venue is it
uh big boy fight
do you remember who the main event was
oh damn I don't uh
look at you dude yeah I still got that
thick neck
and and you're in the sungas yeah my
kids the other day were making fun of
those shorts I was like uh if you guys
not seen my first couple fights yeah
hold off before you pass judgment you
know what I mean these are brass house
Guys these are baggy compared to
yeah I remember they're like well just
being very literally of his guard here
so that's why I dropped him against the
cage and that's why I always understood
wrestling at a higher level with that
incorporated my Jiu Jitsu it's like you
can see here I'm just making sure his
bottom arm can't plant down and then
trying to keep my head in there and then
I was actually thinking I could get a
DARS they're like oh no I'll just go
ahead and take his back and that was a
mistake there of reaching that way and
allowing the underhook to come up and I
didn't learn that until years later
and he uh yeah because jiu jitsu's
clearly his background your striking is
even better at this point even though he
has more fights we can just tell you
striking's a little better than his yeah
he probably would have been more suited
now if he would be a tool fiber yes and
then you're at this point you're a uh
purple belt yeah purple I'm just doing
he's a black belt and was able to catch
him with his arm bar holy [ __ ] smooth
ass arm bar God Doug Smith and black
belt your first [ __ ] fight
remember
I think it was two and two
I'm sorry two thousand or two thousand
and two thousand so I made four grand
four grand and back then you were crying
I thought it was awesome I went and
bought a new uh the new Xbox yeah I
played Halo I bought a uh at that time I
think I got like a uh it was like a 50
inch screen I thought I was I thought I
had made it in life yeah hell yeah those
were the days man and then the next
fight we're gonna watch again there's so
freaking many good fights that you have
you know it's funny actually going back
to you see they don't talk about it
widely but it actually broke his arm in
the fight so did you yeah it's cracked
it and so first of many yeah first of
many so when they talk how many times
you've broken people's arms I'm like
well a couple of put Hardware in so I
know it's confirmed that one I didn't
know if it was confirmed or not because
but later on he had a thing on and his
coach was speaking Brazilian to my coach
like that's broke thanks gave snapped a
lot of dude's arm you're because you're
Jiu Jitsu I feel like you're one of the
especially at heavyweight like the first
Jiu Jitsu where the torque and like the
for like it was just ferocious when you
got something it was like you weren't
doing it just to win it was like see
that's approach and I keep that
mentality now when I train guys I hear
people go oh I didn't get you to tap I'm
like see right there your vocabulary it
tells me your brain's not in the right
spot tapping is not an objective tapping
is for the guy on the other side to
protect himself during training yeah
there's no other option I'm not trying
to make you tap I'm trying to break your
arm even in training I'm going to break
your arm and if you tap I'll stop yeah
right because that should be the
objective in your mind I'm trying to
destroy that limb so there's one less
limb between me and your throat you know
what I mean because eventually I want to
get to your neck to cut off the blood to
your brain if you train for tapping now
you're making it too much supportative
and you're just trying to hurt people
like oh I want you to cry Uncle them all
why are you trying to get a cry Uncle
what does uncle mean I mean like I'm
trying to make you unconscious you're
trying to put you in the emergency
exactly so so even in the gym like I
tell people call the guy was a dick I'm
like look if you go fast you're a dick
but if you're training you put me in an
arm bar and you're slowly applying
pressure not tapping and if I don't tap
to it it's my fault it's not yours
because how do you know that it works or
not you got to keep applying pressure
and oh well I guess it did work and if
it doesn't then I don't tap and say well
you're not breaking the arm it's not
cracking then you know you have improper
Technique we had to restructure what
you're doing wrong are you messing up
the folk on the base the lever is it a
wrong Pivot Point what are you doing
wrong that it's not causing the person's
arm to fracture and if you train like
that then when you get in the real
situation you're ready to go then you're
going to speed it up to me it's like
playing you know if we were to play
baseball if you pitch it over the plate
and you throw it at 70 miles an hour but
you use proper technique I'm good I can
learn and then in the game all I got to
do is speed it up right but if I'm
throwing 90 but I'm throwing way out of
the strike box to protect you if I throw
it into the dirt now I got to do it in
the game and I'll put it over the place
you've never seen it yeah bro you don't
know what you're doing you haven't even
done the proper technique now and when
you say your code as far as coaching are
you only coaching your daughter who's a
freaking Savage Oh you're only really
coaching her well I help out at
syndicate with John Wood and train the
guys there you know we'll help out when
guys want stuff but uh but for the most
part yeah Bella is the one I'm most
serious about uh you know because it
makes sense well you know what I tried
talking her out of being a fighter for
many many years and then you know
finally what became evident that I
wasn't going to win this I was like all
right well let me shift directions and
help you make sure that it goes the
right way and she trains the same way
same demeanor as her dad yeah yeah no
and actually like uh
to a curse I've been blessed with
intelligence which I tell people
sometimes is not a good thing for a
fighter being too intelligent is
actually bad you know I agree to a point
yeah I mean like sometimes being a
little dumb helps you ignorance is bliss
yeah a lot of times when we would be in
the back of the locker room and guys
weren't nervous so I'd just look at him
like that's because you're stupid yeah
you should be yeah I mean you should be
[ __ ] your pants yeah if you're not
you know then there's this pendulum can
swear or swing too far the other way
let's take a little break from chatting
with the myth the legend one of the Hall
of Famers of the UFC heavyweight
division we're talking about Frank bear
Frank Mir is a badass and all you guys
are badasses and listen it's okay to be
scared if you're a badass because we
live in a digital world and you should
be worried about protecting your
identity it's okay to be a little scared
maybe you're not a black belt in Jiu
Jitsu online all right and you're
growing your family maybe you're taking
out mortgages and you're like man I'm
doing all this stuff online I started
thinking about my identity protection
and my friends at Allstate got you
covered you gotta check out Allstate
identity protection the best identity
protection from a brand you can trust
Allstate come on they've been around
since we were kids we know Allstate so
much of life is logging on to digital
lives of our friends and yours right
that's why Allstate developed an
identity protection product that
protects your Digital Life just like
they do your physical life with Allstate
identity protection they'll reimburse
you up to 1 million buckaroos for
out-of-pocket expenses lost wages legal
fees they got you covered wow they also
covered money stolen from your bank
accounts which I've had happened 401k's
hsas and tax returns they got you
covered listen Allstate's been
protecting you for over 90 years that's
how long they've been doing it what I
love about Allstate identity protection
is I have a peace of mind right and I'm
covering the whole Squad my whole fam
all the shops are covered we live in a
digital world man it's easy for people
to access and take your identity but
that's why I'm backed up by Allstate so
when you think identity protection think
Allstate identity protection to find out
if your employer offers All-State
identity protection head to aip.com if
not get a 30-day free trial at aip.com
that's aip.com
schab
Bella has Intelligence and then her
natural ability right now she tested the
pi and this was a year and a half ago
and they tested her against every
Athlete on the female side every weight
class you name the girl if she signed
with the UFC she was on that list Bella
was stronger and more explosive than all
of them she blew them all out of the
water she was the strongest most
explosive athlete they had ever signed
it's hard not like when you have that
type of talent it's hard enough like all
right yeah but then Bella also has what
I always lacked is that like right now
Bella is up in Iowa she has a
scholarship to wrestle she won Nash
Champion wrestler my daughter's a
five-time state champion she's a
national champion wrestler she's natural
in high school and then now she's a
freshman year of college the redshirting
this year she's at Iowa which you know
they just opened up you know the pretty
good school pretty school good to
wrestling school yeah holy [ __ ] she had
full ride to Iowa yeah full rifle they
don't do full ride so they have like I
think about eight scholarships and they
cut them up you know what I mean still
yeah yeah I have no idea yeah so she's
up there wrestling and so they just did
the uh strength test again and she has
the highest vertical on the team she's
the strongest team but then they did now
here's the part where Bella is different
than me and this is why she'll be much
better than I ever was as a fighter
um
she weighs 157 and she's 12 body fat
they actually told her she can't go down
in a weight class Bella eats the same
thing every day it's like chicken rice
vegetable portion control if you know
she has animals at the house you know we
have about 10 bunnies and or 12 bunnies
and like 10 chickens she wakes up before
school every day would take care of him
and feed him she does the most grinding
most Moon Dane work that I would find
mind wrenching and I would find a way
out of it I'm the guy going all right
cool maybe I can convince this person if
I pay them to you know what I mean I'd
be like if I just release it I'm trying
to leverage myself through this right
too I've thought about it too like right
now we're taking care of the bunnies and
I'm like you know if an accident happens
if I just leave the water on long enough
the coyote in the foot doesn't look like
they wear size 13 yeah they did this one
yeah weird this coyote Wilson choose his
dad yeah and so uh she has the
discipline to do the things all three of
my kids actually have it and I think
that's because that was always my
weakness I'm like hey here's my weakness
I can't stick to a diet I can't stick to
this doing the hard stuff the mundane
boring the brush your teeth type I mean
I suck at being consistent with the
exciting [ __ ] to go Spar to go go lift
heavy you're in I'm in and you're a
freak you got away with it I love that
[ __ ] but but as far as like all right
now we need you to go home and make sure
you don't put on video games and sleep
nine hours I'm like oh [ __ ] you know
what I mean I'm going to practice like
what'd you do I stand up all night on
the Xbox yeah
that was me yeah no I have no idea she
was that big of a fruit an issues are
free yeah no in fact actually like I
always am a head coach in every Endeavor
but I like having another coach they
know Robert drives though he's a you
know he's a monster yes right phenomenal
mind so he's her Jiu Jitsu coach you
know so you know when he steps in and
does stuff I don't say anything I'll
make adjustments and go hey you know
Bella like that's cool for jiu jitsu but
in MMA we're actually going to make this
variation yeah we're gonna go and do
this you know but Robert already makes
most of the street fighting UFC yeah
he's almost 99 on we almost agree with
everything
um but there are times I've had to tell
their coaches from a very young age like
hey you know how you do those mental
tests with people you tell the kids all
to stand like in a push-up position you
leave the room or you put them through
some kind of like how far they'll go I'm
like you can't do that to Bella you
should do it she'll kill herself Yes
she'll die if you say hey go on the sun
and last one out I'm like no no don't do
that don't do that she will literally
kill herself it's just that Kobe mention
she will die if you said right now let's
all go into sauna and we're all going to
be in here I'm like if she doesn't win
she's dying like like either you're
gonna have to die too like whoever wants
to beat her just assume you're gonna die
if my kid rushed out of Iowa out of a
Iowa [ __ ] tattoo on my neck the
Hawkeye on my neck
I can't wait till they start doing some
of them
if you want to let you know there's ever
time yeah hell yeah I'll go all right
let's see this fight now this is Tim
Sylvia to me Tim Sylvia
it has to be one of the scariest guys to
ever compete at uh yeah I think at this
time he was 17-0 with like 16 Knockouts
he's like six seven good footwork like
even Tim Sylvia now if you think about
the champion UFC now in Francis or you
think about no Texas zero Dawn I mean I
would put a prime Tim silver against any
of it yeah long boxer knew how to take
this super hard to take down couldn't
take him down yeah he's a monster and he
actually knew that when we strategized
for the fight I'm like you know what I
think I can do I think I can keep
blasting his little knob like so that
was my goal actually was just keep him
in the legs and then when he took me
down here I thought he was just gonna
stand up so we're sitting there and he's
moving me towards the cage like oh
really holy [ __ ] do you want to play
this game you're gonna do this with me
all right cool so then I just saw the
arm and this her deed was like I didn't
see
oh so I'm like all right I know it broke
I'm just gonna keep ripping on it and
see what one of the greatest highlights
of all time in the UFC
because that I think that's when people
were like oh [ __ ] [ __ ] too and her
being's like dude your your arm yeah and
that shows you want to [ __ ] Savage
have you ever talked to her about it no
yeah so they're sitting there in the
dark at that point Dana and everybody's
freaking out on her they think he
stopped the fight wrong they just
screwed up the heavyweight match like
what do you do do you restart them if
you restart them you put them back in
the arm bar like what do we do which
thank God they didn't restart me back in
the arms of his arm yeah at least he had
a plate it would have been one armed you
know he probably would have took it off
completely
so so with all this pandemonium is
happening like oh you screwed it up even
to the point after the fight uh uh Bruce
didn't even announce me as a new
heavyweight champ he just announced he's
the winner oh Helm he's great he
apologized about to this day of my
friends right everybody's booing and
then when they showed it up on the
prompter that's when he actually go yeah
well even right there they grew up with
Margaret Goodman The Physician at the
time she's like kind of like touching it
and she's like looking at her like well
I don't know he's saying he's fine like
you know she's looking at him like ah
well you know like is it good is it not
you know like what's going on like so
there's all this like confusion on
what's about to occur and then when they
see the video pop and then they came
back and said that you know obviously
but you knew it pop oh yeah well not
even just the feeling of it breaking
like it went from like holding on to a
stick 12s and just feels like a bag of
potato chips yeah like there's
completely no connection now from his
wrist to his upper arm and it shows you
what a badass Tim sylvius because even
he was like why would you stop yeah and
everyone was like dude well he actually
told me later on that he knew he broke
his arm and he was hoping to get a
restart and which makes him a Savage
right he's trying to get the fight
restarted so that he knows he has about
10-15 seconds to start swinging and
maybe catch me with a left yeah but you
know what hey man Kudos too my hats off
man as I've been like hey take him to
the hospital right now so then he walks
out of the ring you know that part and
he's trying to play it off that he's not
hurt so he has his hands up you know
where that happens right one of the fans
high five
so when we go back to the locker room I
can hear him screaming oh I bet yeah
hell yeah because then the adrenaline
folds out there you see the pop real big
oh it's bad I mean literally well it
broke his radius and his all now so he
had to have a plate with his arm
terrible yeah like the worst case
scenario for a fighter like you're out
for a hot sake Shacks front row right
yeah see at this point it was like oh
boo yeah like Nickelback back there too
just crushing it oh yeah those were the
days
Yeah Tim silver too I I was watching his
highlights the other day because I'm a
weirdo I'm like yo this guy in his prime
he compete right now both you guys could
like you look at the Champs now I'm like
man tinsel would give Francis and Sarah
gone some problems
that all the time I mean it's one of the
best highlights ever nuts us dude and
dude that's [ __ ] Prime Tim Silvia he
was such a Savvy you see how just bowed
completely ripped a piece
and just even the way you're controlling
this posture you know with your legs
you know and that's actually why I train
people that way in my gym if we're
rolling and you put me in an arm bar and
if I pick you up to my waist and you
haven't stopped me you got to stop the
arm bar in my gym like okay let go
because if we were fighting you [ __ ]
up already slam you into the mat correct
so either learn to let go of the arm bar
when someone's lifting you or learn how
to make sure you can avoid being slammed
yep so don't use the rule system because
then when you do that then you go to the
fight it's like well do you know how to
stop a slam well no because no one does
it in practice so I mean there's ways to
do things to make it safe to simulate to
where you're prepared for them yes you
know that makes sense
right yeah and this is dude this is uh
so you had this fight uh this is UFC 81
Yep this is uh
because you fought Brock twice right in
81 and then UFC 100. UFC 81 because that
was right around the Super Bowl I
remember I was at the Super Bowl in
Phoenix and we found a bar to watch his
fight I've never been more into a fight
I've cared more about a fight than I
wasn't in than this one because I felt
like it was the UFC fighters versus the
rest like the WWE guy see and I was like
oh Frank better [ __ ] win this man
because I just and I've met Brock he's a
great guy and I fought his training
partner would be on the same cards he's
such a good dude he's actually a good
dude but there's like so much and yeah
you guys were Connor and Aldo before
Connor animosity dude in the build up it
was I mean to me one of the top like
rivalry fights of all [ __ ] time so
funny you say that right so it's like
speed and technique it's just a person
so going into this fight I didn't really
follow pro wrestling that well I mean I
knew like Hulk Hogan is and whatnot you
know what I mean if you sit there and go
well hey like you know at this point
have you just said who's like a
different program like I could tell you
this yeah I mean like I don't know man
I'm not that I'm not you know hey that's
cool but also I don't lose my mom yeah I
don't know you know and so uh uh I
looked at him as a guy that was a
two-time national champ 10 like five
that's how you should look that's how I
was thinking about oh my God man this
guy's a high level I'm watching
wrestling matches hey man this guy took
Stephen Neal you know who's one of the
greatest heavyweight wrestlers we've
ever had this guy's top five probably
you know what I mean if God is
Collegiate wrestlers are like phenomenal
wrestler Beast monster so then it's
backstage we're doing all the different
interviews and whatnot I forgot I wish I
could remember who it was but as I'm
walking out of one of the rooms one of
the other Fighters he goes hey man like
hey you know what you got to make sure
you take care of this one this is pro
wrestling versus MMA I'm like yeah yeah
and I walked off like oh wait a minute
no no this ain't pro wrestling versus it
man yeah there's a legitimate College
wrestlers converted over to MMA like
Freak No like no you guys think he's a
pro wrestler like oh damn it man like
that actually kind of made me nervous
I'm like oh this isn't fair you know
some pressure now I'm like oh man yeah
there's a lot of pressure and it's like
hey you're fighting an actor I'm like
yeah an actor who's in being gold you
know like before like no yeah yeah
he is a set freak which obviously showed
off throughout you know throughout his
career
hit it
young Brewster yeah he has a flat top
the dick tattoo on his chest and you
guys were just talking so much [ __ ]
going into this and then the second one
was even worse yeah
but he got me top and here's the thing
about Brock like you can't take anything
away from Brock because he didn't have a
ton of experience of the [ __ ] wolves
man well you know what yeah what he's
hearing was one of his first fights yeah
steamrolled him and Heath Aaron's a
veteran thought he died like he fought
big wrestlers like him
uh the big cat uh Tom Erickson Tom
Erickson yeah yes in Pride I mean he had
a win over him kicked him in the body
and like you know so
I thought it was a smart move from the
UFC because here they give it to him at
this time I'm a former champ fighting
him and here hits his debut so if he
doesn't do well he gets caught or
something happens it's your first fight
you took on too many veterans right yeah
if he wins he's automatically propelled
you're legitimate here you'd be the
legitimate guy we can move you right
within two fights into such a smart
matchmaking yep
yeah he was so talented he even played
football and then tried out for the
Vikings he did I think he made it all
the way up to like the final cut the
Final Cut maybe further than I did about
three weeks further than me
then you were nervous for this fight
going into it yeah no definitely I knew
how good of his wrestling was I knew how
strong he was and and also too like not
even just strength I always tell people
like one thing is this is quickness you
know what I mean like oh so athletic so
fast
yeah he we haven't seen anything like
him no I really haven't
and the game plan for this because you
knew he was going to shoot that last
double I knew that as long as the fight
went on eventually my MMA experience
would catch him that was kind of I mean
as at that moment probably should have
had a better like plan a plan B plan C
but it was kind of like hey man as long
as you can't get me out of there
eventually you know I mean like there
you see like not I'm starting to gain
confidence like okay that was closer
because the first couple alarm bars
weren't even close that arm bar he had
to jump he landed on his hip he gave a
position it fell down and uh I was like
all right as long as I keep moving keep
in the fight keep it here eventually
he's going to make a mistake and
especially when your you know leg locks
and collucks like he's not it I don't
give there's not enough hours in the day
you need to learn that that like you're
going down a weird rabbit hole man no
and that's why he's trying to keep it
even Jiu Jitsu here yeah just all right
keep going for armed Barn bar and then
just stood up yeah this was filthy I was
able to swing over almost kind of like a
reap that pulled back and then was able
to lock the figure four on the leg the
happiest I've ever been for a fight that
I was involved in I felt like it was
like [ __ ] yeah no it really was it came
down to so many people afterwards you
know what I mean was it's MMA versus pro
wrestling I'm like all right which then
made me happy because eventually by the
time it brought in it's like oh now he's
an MMA fighter he's not a pro wrestler
now he's a guy who's trained you know
what I mean which
like you said dude the guy was a
Collegiate wrestler a high level yeah I
mean like the top five biggest freaks
we've had in the UFC like he's such a
size look at Joe Silva you you know the
guy we're like how's that 10 speed man
he has to go way back yeah is that there
you see way more happier than that that
the Tim Sylvia fight obviously the
controversy with Tim Sylvia breaking his
yeah that was hard to be like excited
about it after the Tim Sylvia fight just
because like everybody's booing no one's
happy so then I tried to reap he jumped
over I was to come up behind with a calf
cutter and then just look how hard that
is to pull off a knee bar like that at
this level let's take a little break
from chatting with Frank Mir with some
chatty Kathy's right but it's a fun one
this guy's fights are insane
but listen if you're watching this
you're like man Frank and Brennan they
look like they're in the zone these two
are chatting back and forth like a
debate over here this is fantastic how
do they get into that flow State well
this Flow State that experts talk about
when you're focused on just a single
task and you're knocking things out
you're creating things you're
remembering names here's a little secret
it's called Alpha Brain Alpha Brain Buy
on it my friends at on it created the
best nootropic on the freaking planet
it's gonna help you speed up your brain
help you remember names help your
cognitive abilities in your brain man I
need all the help I can get and thank
God for Alpha Brain from on it and
here's the thing I'll bring so sure
you're gonna love they're so sure you're
gonna love their product Alpha Brain
that they're going to give you a
guarantee or your money back you don't
have to ship the product back keep the
product we're so sure you're gonna like
it they can guarantee your money back if
you don't but you will so don't worry
about it don't sweat it man if you're
worried about your sense of caffeine or
whatever it is like I can't drink coffee
cool Alpha brings caffeine free no
Jitters all natural we got you baby on
it the best supplements on planet Earth
the best nootropic on planet Earth you
can save 10 off by going to audit.com
schabonit.com all right if you get 10
off Alpha Brain or you can go to your
local Walmart who wants to go to Walmart
you should go to audit.com
you get 10 off Alpha Brain and all
supplements and workout gear at
audit.com shop you're welcome you're
probably watching us at work right now
you probably went to the coffee machine
you're at the water cooler and
everybody's talking about this new thing
called Kratom you're like what is Kratom
kratom's basically a limitless bill you
ever seen that movie with Bradley Cooper
where he's just popping a little pill
and getting things done he's doing
algebra and dealing with stocks and
basically became Elon Musk yeah man
that's Kratom that's what it does for
you and here's a little secret for you
kids out there it's also all natural
it's all safe we got you covered man and
if you gotta try create them you're
thinking about it you need to go where
the company you can trust and that's
where my friends at happy hippo come in
it's the only brand I trust and happy
hippo they have in all of variety of
forms gummies they have cool pink
lemonade shots they have regular pills
which I also take but if I'm if I'm on
the go and I'm about to go on stage Do
stand up I'm on tour I'm doing a podcast
fight companion whatever it is a big
interview boom one little boom pink
lemonade Kratom what and it works
instantly for me that's the only brand
that I trust too it's happy hippo so if
you want to try Kratom you want to try
the only Kratom you should ever try if
you want to try Kratom that has only one
ingredient we're talking about Kratom
you gotta trust my friends at happy
hippo because the wild west out there so
visit happyhippo herbals.com promo code
is thick boy you get 20 off for Life use
that code as many times you want send it
to your friends your family your gay
Aunt whoever it is you get 20 off for
life of the best Kratom on planet Earth
go to happy hippo herbals.com promo code
stick Roy 20 soft for life now let's get
back to the program from chatting with
Frank Mayer and actually you know what
it's funny he could have been out see
his leg is right on the back of my knee
if he would have just drove his foot
forward he would have to push out yep
and his knee line would have came out
but again he did it I missed his armpit
this is the language he does not speak
no like he has no clue down there he was
just like oh [ __ ] there's pressure on my
knee here
the knee bar I mean granted especially
if you don't know what you're doing get
really hurt there no because he's almost
I mean I barely actually had it yeah uh
honestly an inch and it's not and you've
been out yeah he's out but I think too
those guys freak out if especially if he
does he's not familiar with that like
the pressure on the knee yeah well and
he has a lot to get going he actually
complained to Dana afterwards because
Dana told me because he complained about
masagati like fire that guy because my
knee was about to blow out it was he was
telling him because I'm screaming and
tapping how many times do I got attacked
he goes my knee is about to explode I'm
screaming here because masagati you know
if that's why you even see as I'm
loading up his leg I feel him tapping so
I didn't apply more pressure but I'm not
gonna let go yeah no still referee comes
right so I have it locked in and that's
why you actually see me kind of looking
I'm like well why is it what are we
doing here yeah like I mean how many
times I mean like I won right like when
Brock was complaining look at Joe with
here there when Brock was complaining
was Dan like don't be a [ __ ] dude
yeah that kid's kind of savage on the
ground yeah what'd you expect to happen
now your dad was there too yeah yep
he'll lose Corner yeah my dad was my
first martial arts instructor they
started owning a Kimball karate school
and my dad came from Cuba so like boxing
and wrestling were very big and so our
our kimpo karate looked very much like
above the waist kickboxing yeah so is
that still alive oh yeah still healthy
still I feel like Cubans last forever he
still gets up at you know at 5 30 in the
morning he finishes six mile run you
know oh gee well that's where your
daughter is yeah he's very similar in
that way there you go wakes up early you
know my dad for every breakfast it's the
same thing it's six egg whites with one
yolk and a tuna with a little bit of
mozzarella to keep it closed and that's
it you know I'm like yeah he's just yeah
we go on vacation and I'm like all right
man like yeah and I love lifting weights
but I can't give me the new car no no
it's never going to happen if I'm doing
cardio though you better run the same
direction I am there's something bad
if you see me running on the beach
there's a problem that's kind of cool
that's dead throw your dabs those in
your corner now you're in your
daughter's school yeah that's pretty
funny it hasn't worked out yet but I
want him to also like all that yeah
that's that's one of the both of you
yeah that's actually why even now like
I'm trying to heal up a lot of my
injuries and stuff and taking some
things seriously next year I'm gonna go
and fight again because actually I want
to fight once on the same car with Bella
oh damn that's my last fight she can
headline the card I can open it you know
what I mean type things like you know
that way like I said are you your
comment event she's Main Event yeah well
enough that we can Corner each other
enough of a split oh yes he can't do
that we couldn't do that but have a song
about in between or something I could do
that yeah yeah there was something along
those lines
I'd go to that how many times is that
gonna happen in history never yeah so I
mean I mean
barring you know what I mean like
lightning striking you know a car
accident some [ __ ] you know Bella's
UFC champ whoever Champion whatever
League she wants to join yeah I agree
there's just no I would say no she's as
much I mean it's like me when I look at
Bow nickel I'm like what do you think is
having that guy I'm like he's a champ
dude like lose weight or get a bigger
weight class because yeah unless he like
kids his head at a bar fight or
something
yeah there's nothing so here's the inter
heavyweight championship and why was it
an interim I'm trying to think what year
this was
um why was it an intern yeah so this is
no you know what I think Randy didn't he
retire like give it away no they came
back
oh well because then Randy lost uh uh
Brock that's how Brock became champ
right yeah but that wasn't there until I
don't know you know what I don't
remember uh so and here's the thing
though no girls the only thing I don't
remember stuff like that uh it's too
hard to keep it I mean it might be we
both have CT but I don't know yeah
I don't know you know I just that's the
best thing about CT you don't know yeah
you don't know yeah I'll forget my car
keys like [ __ ] here we go dude you know
what my wife uses it on me that's what
pisses me off
you never said that so
[ __ ] it's getting mad I'm like no shut
up that's like me I'll do my my girl my
friend I'm like what's her name she's
like you've met Natalie ten times she's
like your CT like or I just don't give a
[ __ ] I put it on that like it just
wasn't that important yeah I'm like
literally I have too much [ __ ] going on
just on the level of [ __ ] that that my
friend's name is dead last yeah so keep
telling me her name uh yeah so this is
gonna get 32 no punk if they do you're
still only 29 here yeah got into UFC
young oh this fight was nutsos too is it
too I mean it's a Jitsu guy this has to
be one of your favorite fights yeah well
then actually as far as my career-wise
the second one between us was probably
my favorite fight because because I was
Oh I thought the second one this is the
first this is the first one yeah oh I
like the second one yeah yeah I want the
second one uh they're both good we watch
both
so much both so in this one I had a
really knew that like I'm like you know
what he really underestes my stand-up
you know he has a lot of confidence to
stand up I'm gonna just make sure we
just don't go to the ground and kind of
throw him for a loop you know what I
mean and so then we fought the second
time uh a little too confident with it
that was one of the times I learned in
my life like hey just because things
went well the first time this isn't a
guarantee it's gonna go it'll be like
hey chill out you still got to work for
you know I mean that's where all your
years I've been will get to it when we
fight in the same time but that's where
all your years of Jiu Jitsu and that
muscle memory because yeah if I remember
correctly you're kind of out right you
get rocked and then you just wait you're
like cut yeah no my wife and I we
actually make jokes about that all the
time so after the fight we're talking
and I'm talking she goes like what do
you remember I'm like I just was
underwater I kind of felt some legs
I was getting choked and then I woke up
with a Kimora yeah and she goes and then
I'm watching like wow that's really cool
she goes you did all of that like half
calm like yeah if you do something
longer yeah like you know muscle memory
you're just going through that flow she
goes like so literally like if in your
sleep I'm like yeah let's keep that as a
story
yeah but dude and yeah this is [ __ ]
Prime no gear here man yeah no they give
me very little chance this is one of the
examples I talked about we were talking
about on the show with Harrison earlier
when before the fight no one gave me a
chance to win because here's the former
Pride Champion I think at the Timeline
Number Two fighter in the world
everyone's so excited yeah it was over
with for me you know what I mean and
again the UFC is like here's Frank Mayer
yeah you know it's like beat our poster
boy and again if you lose to him it's
not the end of the world he is [ __ ]
pretty famous pretty freaking good so
it's kind of like a no lose situation
for Brock Lesnar for for no Guerra but
if you're no Guerra this is exactly
where he should be at you know you can't
give him any warm-up fights
and so uh so that you use uh the
discipline here the strategy was Heavy
stand up yeah just just keep on our feet
keep loose I felt like yeah it was Heavy
very heavy footed as a boxer and then it
was actually to open up with hands and
then when he started getting kind of
angry I figured I could play into his
ego and then if I popped him a few times
he would step in aggressive and be heavy
with his footwork so then I could start
chopping his legs you know I mean then
he'd be predictable with his footwork I
would know where his foot was landing
and he wouldn't be able to block as well
or move his foot out of the way and I
could come down hard and beat up his uh
his legs I mean really beat the [ __ ] out
of him man
that you really giving it to him yeah
here I was actually just kind of
screwing with him like here because they
couldn't get a hard shot off so I came
up just controlled the ankles and make
sure nothing crazy happened and this
again was a ploy to really just play
into his ego because he was very
confident on the master type of mindset
so I'm like oh you know what that's you
know it's a uh it's a whole it's a
weakness it's something I can work with
you know it's like oh you got Pride I
can work with that and then he really
doubled down on his box and got way
better at boxing yeah he's a good right
hand you know it's solid you know I mean
you know him and his brother used to go
down to the Cuba at the box so I mean at
this point he's still a really good
boxer in his career yeah but I mean he's
thrown no kicks and he keeps his feet
flat you know he's very much of a boxer
but I mean it does add to his power he
hits hard you know he does people don't
want to acknowledge it I'm like Ben the
guy no he once he got out of the Muay
Thai stance from the first part of he
watched his first part of his career
like when he was in Pride he fought more
of a Thai boxer style you know and his
boxing wasn't that great he threw more
kicks and punches and then once he kind
of settled down his stance a little bit
his hands became heavier and he relied
more on his the strength which you know
look at his shoulders and his neck he's
uh you know he hits hard and when I you
know I always do know Garrett was a big
deal you know especially in our world
but you know in Brazil those guys
they're they're uh Tom Cruise's
legendaries I didn't realize that so the
UFC initially offered me him in my
hometown to Denver I was like no I was
young and Wild on everybody I don't have
anybody on my team to go let's be smart
about this let's do it in Denver I was
like no I want to do it in Brazil I want
to knock him out in front of his home
crowd like okay so then you know
obviously did that I ended up getting uh
hit really hard in the face and losing
the fight that would have been much more
of a strategy to have him up in Denver
just because I've walked around in them
you if you don't prepare for that's a
whole you were really fighting other
creatures especially as a heavier guy
because I was a cardio guy and yeah I
would have heard him I mean you would
have had a verdum versus Velasquez yeah
situation yes sir and he just wish
someone bad team like hey dude let's
just do it in Denver here's the
advantages but everyone's like yeah not
come out in Brazil
oh what you knocked him out in Vegas
and he's a guy too he's 32 and he he's
in his primary but he had so much uh
kind of Miles wearing tip miles from The
Pride days like yeah
[ __ ] his neck up fatal fights yeah the
crow cop fights I mean the kid got ran
over by a motor a pickup truck dump
truck yeah
so I mean he's definitely he's faced a
lot of adversity which made for his
mental toughness but I mean eventually
the body you know it can only answer
that call so many times yeah and then
catches up with you
but you're having success on the feet so
you're getting pretty confident here
yeah which I took that I built it into
it you know and then the footwork I
understood because we I could walk with
my punches on him and step outside the
lead leg or step inside you know
stepping on a triangle at all times as I
was attacking to make sure I didn't come
down the middle
I mean but you're absolutely dominating
him even on the ground the ground and
pounds working for you on the feet
you're Landing he's he really hasn't
done much yet no this this in today's uh
UFC is a 10-8 round yeah I thought so
too and actually after the end when they
called it was a 10-9 I'm like holy [ __ ]
what do I have to do to get a teenager
back then you literally kill him yeah
you literally have to chop his head off
like all right 10-9
now which is actually messes me up
because sometimes I'll still watch
fights like oh that's not a 10-day I'm
like yeah I know it is because I would
have thought that was to begin with but
I kind of got you know Jaded by another
yeah good condition that like you had to
kill somebody even now it's [ __ ]
tough to get Ted eight like I'll watch
something I was like Jesus Christ that's
the 10-8 and they go 10-9 I'm like what
in the world are they watching
no no I assume you got paid more for
this one than the first fight yeah doing
some real money on this one
you remember
um yeah a lot oh my God that right hand
man and that's the end of the Bell
I do remember they took me to the back
and bonus to me this is the first time I
think I actually got a back room bone
like the discretionary bonus those are
fun yeah I was like 250. which I thought
was you know at that time that was more
than I actually made for the fight so
that may make sense now
and this is what you guys were allowed
to have sponsors I mean you are
sponsored up echo which I loved Echo
yeah I was with Echo for years
yeah what do you got Echo you got that
tilt
get some good money makers on there uh
neutral box yep I actually still do
stuff with Nutrabolics yeah oh sick good
group of guys
Jason and I yeah really yeah yeah uh
Jason what's the other guy's name I've
met those guys yeah Jason Weiner and
then uh uh that's funny I have a funny
story I'll tell you off here because I
don't want to let their secret go yeah
there's a funny thing with the name
that's hilarious
um yeah I just remember this there was
so much hype in this fight because the
hardcores knew no gear from The Pride
days yeah those legendary [ __ ] out there
they thought that actually you know how
many people told me afterwards the fight
was fixed I'm like guys I'm good and
he's good but I mean that really like
you think we orchestrated this as a fix
you think no girl agreed against his ass
whoops yeah first round like that he's a
legend he's like yeah let's do this if
it was a fixed fight he would have been
beating my ass and then make a mistake
and then I caught himself yeah I mean
like or so he was fixed he would he
would for sure win right like you know
yeah she put a lot of he was supposed to
win yes correct uh were you a underdog
on the Vegas cars do you remember oh
yeah
yeah that right uh uppercut keeps
Landing for you yeah just again he
doesn't he keeps his hands and then
spreads his elbows so the center Line's
open so just I would throw a strike up
and then that time was like a shovel jab
and just step off center and even as
good as he was at Jiu Jitsu you know
he's one of the legends of it I felt
like your Jiu Jitsu and modern MMA just
was more kind of dangerous yeah like
you're to me like doing it wrong he's
dangerous but you're on the ground Frank
mayor it's [ __ ] dangerous well I have
more of a catch wrestling style I always
tell people that that is more akin to
what works in MMA
whereas you know he still was able to do
a lot of stuff and look how many
triangle finishes he had triangles are
hard to finish against two guys know
what they're doing I mean like when's
last time you saw one yeah you know and
you're statistically hard to get I mean
I don't remember the last time Broly and
I've ever been caught in a triangle I
mean I don't remember the last time I've
caught anybody who's a blue belt or
higher in a triangle I mean like if you
say hey one's not to cut a brown
building a triangle I'm like never like
it's just dogs I mean with a ghee maybe
but nogi no and then now we're punching
each other yeah it happens it's very
difficult
he has a bad knockout there's your pops
again man correct how could you not be
boom that straight left was there all
day and then you got I remember uh as as
your career started going too you got
really into you weren't you boxing with
the the boxing team down there in Vegas
I got really excited but I haven't
started spawning with like uh bermaine
stivern yeah there we go I mean I put on
boxing shoes wear a helmet go and then
go okay we're boxing boxing to a fault
to a point where like I kind of took it
too far yeah and it started messing up
my and that's why in The Mark hunt fight
you see me actually do some things I
would have done from because it was too
much boxing sparring and they got caught
right on the ear and then I watched them
like yeah that's that would have done
that I do that all the time boxing but I
can't do that and you know so I was like
all right look all the Arts Jiu Jitsu
boxing wrestling they're great but if
you take them two down too far they
actually get you hurt do it and a lot of
guys fall into that kind of trap because
you think about like uh you know Andre
Lasky when he's working at Wild Card his
stance got real narrow and they start
getting beat up what are you doing dude
yeah I mean and you could do with all
the Arts not one is more prone not to
making that mistake no they all have
their faults
to the super high level it's like well
Daddy Gonna Get You know you know it it
doesn't work anymore like all the basics
work and that's integrated them together
with the timing you know it's its own
art being an MMA you know
and this I think this fight was right
after uh I fought no gear so I was
really rooting for you here
because he beat me I was like come on
Freddy yeah because actually that for
the fight because you're not talking
because we're like oh that's right we
were it's a guy yeah let's work it out
we'll talk yeah because me and Frank
because I remember because I beat uh I
think I beat Gonzaga I beat Crow cop and
you were doing the interview and I've
always been a fan of yours right forever
I remember you're doing it every year
like yeah that Brendan Shaw looks good I
was like oh [ __ ] yeah but I mean it was
and then I remember because a lot of
guys don't understand this remember we
went backstage we met like hey man we
saw the fight oh yeah yeah talk this I'm
like all right this is the business
everybody has to you got to have an
opponent across from your face and it's
just it's weird when these guys get too
upset because I always tell people hey
you know what if right now during the
fight any fight anybody's fighting if
they cut the power
they go all right fights are over with
sorry people go home and we're all gonna
go next door and drink beer yeah you
know who most likely I'd probably be
drinking with yeah the guy that I was
fighting sorry like who do I have a
naked related to it's like well we got
the most in common we have the same
interests likes we understand the same
sacrifices you know we're on the same
page you know so when people like oh you
hate the guy you're fighting them all
like that's like playing like you think
the guy playing DN hates the officer
yeah I've never hated anybody I didn't
need that motivation
yeah I was rooting for your heart here
because uh no gear came you know knocked
me out Brazil and then uh what's funny
about that is I remember you I was a big
favorite over no dinner in Brazil
because he's older and I was the young
buck coming off the crow cop knockout
and then uh the plan with UFC goes yeah
you beat him they told my coach you're
probably gonna get Brock Lesnar next for
you know and then fight for the time
like I almost start just old Brazilian
dude I just overlooked them yeah I get
two here at this point after the first
fight I was like oh you know what he's
not gotten more athletic he hasn't
gotten more light on his feet you know
what I mean like so this is going to
look exactly like the first one and you
Molly like that that if that second
round we went to score 10-8 again yeah
it wasn't a very you know competitive
fight and then so I I can get I even
like oh this could be another walk in
the park yeah I'm surprised he took it
to be honest I mean oh he wanted it so
bad and he really had in his mind though
yeah he just you know yeah I think when
I first fight he said he had staph
infection he had a knee injury it was
everything I mean that's why something I
kind of made jokes I'm like dude
it was every excuse in the book why he
lost the fight I'm like you know just
fighting's like poker man like I mean
there's a lot of skill involved but
there's a lot of luck too sometimes the
hands you get dealt that day is the hand
you get dealt you know what I mean and
so uh you know sometimes guys just have
a hard time just wrapping their brain
around them like Hey guys you're not
fighting a dude from the bar you're not
fighting some guy that doesn't train you
know it's all this guy does we both are
just real good Fighters you know I mean
like there's days I go in the gym and I
roll with guys I'm like oh today's a
good day there's days I go in there and
same guy tapped the day before now I'm
getting caught like [ __ ] I mean we're
all within inches of each other everyone
has their off days too like did you have
any fights where you won't like I'd wake
up and I'm like I don't feel like doing
this yeah no I've had like [ __ ]
literally can I do it tomorrow yeah and
the time I felt like that I always had
bad nights in the office I remember the
Roy Nelson in the finale I just woke up
I'm like man if we could just do this
tomorrow I'd be stoked like that's not
how it works dumbass no that's why
actually too like with so much about the
training condition with Bella would you
trains there's so much about me trying
to Prime her up for a certain like okay
you don't feel good today we're not
going to explode we have to take an
explosive day let's not do it but there
are days when it's like okay today we're
supposed to do this you know feel like
you know what we're going to do it
anyways today isn't about the physical
aspect of what we're going it's all
mental today's a mental day you know you
don't want to do it I'm going to go
ahead and watch not let her know that
make sure that there's no injuries that
occur because she's not you know in the
green zone right now she's gotta fight
through it but we're going to learn how
to go ahead and compete when we're off
yep because sometimes you do especially
with women you know I mean there's
there's more aspects of them being off
than us but I'm learning about them like
what do we got to deal with like I'm
having like coaching a female is not
like it's different it's different yeah
I mean there's some similarities and
there's some that just don't there's a
lot more to it
was able to build up here and then I'm
sitting there building up and really
honestly like I mean we're like besides
my hand holding onto that ankle thank
God that was the only thing that kept
her from stopping the fight he goes for
that Guillotine really royally [ __ ] up
there yeah so I was able to pull out two
yep to keep out of the arm bar from that
I blocked I thought I was in a half
guard sweep him I was like okay is this
tight yeah it was super tight but then
this is I'm still actually asleep so I'm
just watching it and as you guys hear me
commentating right now I can't tell you
what was going through my head I'm still
asleep this isn't me this is you're
still out of it this is my Reptilian
Brain yes I am still not awake but it's
like not away look at this I don't
remember any of this but even the
movement stepping over the head that's
not me yet look at you I'll tell you
when I woke up and look he's grimacing
there and then this is the worst break
of all time I woke up here the staff
that's when I woke up I was like oh [ __ ]
I got an arm and I'm kind of like waking
up boom the worst injury you can get
you're talking spiral fresh I think that
actually was one of the words well maybe
some of the shin breaks barring like the
Anderson and the my you know those
aren't as bad because those guys you
know those guys are doing to themselves
yes though the torque on that fan
yeah spiral fracture I think it broke
his arm at like nine different places
the humans
yeah they thought it ended his career
actually I did oh
my God I mean literally I mean what
we've watched you know the Tim Sylvia
submission this submission you're
talking about top five of all time this
one I I number one just for what no
nugira stood for his Jujitsu his
background he refused to tap like no
Guerra was like man I'd rather die than
tap you like say less check this out
yeah I'm like well be careful and again
just the torque on this and you're kind
of out of it yeah and just how you just
chop it through like butter dude the
transition look at this yeah
control stepping over the head you're
still kind of out of it and these groups
in right here already now most guys
would tap here
most guys tap there he's just rolling I
think he's gonna get out of it
oh my god dude
that's why you don't tap the train to
make people tap
I mean I mean one of the greatest
submissions all the time man yeah it's
usually get hurt and go that one broke
huh
you want to double check this one buddy
like you guys [ __ ] me over the Sylvia
fight everyone was beating you know her
was good I mean he was on my side of
that one I'm like hey man I don't think
they're gonna be confused on this one a
major job easier tonight yeah we got her
back but they don't get confused about
this one which is kind of funny that
herb had to rough both of them
submissions I've ever done I do I mean
the most vicious submissions and he's
just in the back the entire Medical
Teams oh yeah his arm is just a
nightmare he was in pain they had to put
him almost in like a complete brace to
be able to even walk him to enjoy that
flight back to Brazil
nightmare dude we have broken Romans
like holy [ __ ] yeah actually and for
that submission that was that year I won
at the MMA Awards submission of the year
and come back of the Year both in the
same night really yeah that makes sense
yeah come back to the year I mean that
you were oh I was Rocky I mean like I
said like afterwards when I'm going
through this is because Lindell the
judicials that came up to me is like
what happened so he's like yeah you high
hit him here he's like explaining to me
what I did he goes and you you blocked
The Shins you came over you cut you came
through you lost you went too deep over
the top you re-rolled them you kept the
head out you know and then pinned the
head down like all right I got you yo
that sounds sweet all right cool I got
you so I went back and translated it I
was like all right cool I'll tell you
what I did but yeah until I came up on
the second roll like I never remember
the first roll because people were
asking the first roll I'm like saying we
rolled twice I don't remember that when
I watched the video I was like oh okay
yeah super high level just as
transitioning all the flow it's so
filthy man American Jiu Jitsu [ __ ]
that's definitely on the map now yeah
boom I mean oof
and I assumed for that one does this one
you're making kind of Big Boy money at
this point uh
I think I made 400.
that was actually the Pinnacle of my
career probably this Moses I was making
400 for fights that's insane yeah yeah I
think the most fun I ever made for a
fight was the Brock fight uh UFC 100 I
made like 600. interested only six up
discretionary bonus is that UFC that was
part of it yeah because at that time I
hadn't had the 400 000 I think I was on
like you know whatever it was a win and
like you know like a 150 and 150. and
they made it up to Twitter it was like
over 600. that's cool yeah yeah I
remember is it now is that the I forget
which fight Brock gets on the mic and
he's like I'm not drinking this Bud
Light [ __ ] they were so mad he was
mad at Coors or Bud lighters I'm gonna
drink cores and then Dana just like beat
it out yeah corrected him on that one is
that it now you have so many fights I
can do this all [ __ ] day yeah that
was cool hell yeah when's last time we
watched them a couple of those not in
years man you know we did one of these
shows with my buddy Eric Griffin who's a
comic who knows nothing about fighting
so it's me educating them I'm fighting
and the first episode we did is we
watched all my losses have you ever
watched all your losses I want to slit
my [ __ ] throat oh my God it was it's
brutal man yeah I think we ended on the
nogere fight yeah it was awful
but these were fun yeah these were good
yeah next time we'll go over some Lots
yeah it depends on the you know some
people will attack their losses we gotta
make sure I have a room I'm not gonna go
home for the night to get a little drunk
like slurring his words like hey it's
competing might have to have your
therapist on standby maybe just watched
Frank's losses man
but that did those bring good memories
to you oh yeah definitely you know
what's actually the most exciting thing
about my life is it like there's times
like you know the way my house is laid
up my kids rooms are on the other side
of the house basically you know and so
like I'll walk over there and go say
good night or go see what they're doing
from my bedroom and I walk over and
there's been a couple times like you
know a cage my you know my uh my middle
son my 16 year old you know I'll open
the doors I walk in he's on the iPad
he's watching dad fight it's like that
like chokes me up there's times where
just like you know because you always
want to be your kid's hero 100 like you
know there's a day that he's gonna look
at me as just a man and see me as as
valuable and all the flaws that
obviously every man possesses but it's
cool just to be your kid's a superhero
it's a small amount of time in life did
you get to be that then I you know and
some men never afford themselves that
opportunity you agree and I have that
opportunity so I sit there and look I'm
like oh man right and all my kids are
just and I know every dad says this but
like mine I can actually sit down with a
chalkboard and show you they're Superior
to me they are far and above better than
what I ever was and you know cage
already is a freshman uh his freshman
year he won stayed at 195 for 4am at
Bishop Gorman oh he's a big kid yeah and
then uh
and so he's yeah he second string
linebacker as a sophomore the number
four team in the country any second
string on the varsity yeah oh wow I got
a funny story I'll tell you we'll end
off with cage because everybody talk
Bella and then roro he's 13. so he's
still making sure it's also too like you
know even though their dads Frank mayor
this UFC Legend sometimes kids they just
view his dad so they're not really into
like the stuff you're into so when he
beat a senior so that's him stepping off
the mat oh wow yeah that's a that's a
profession in high school you know he's
mentioned 315 already but the summer
before his freshman year started oh
you're doing some Savage yeah yeah
squats 455 you know yeah and so uh he's
quick as hell we're actually now he's
just working with a speed coach so he
can get him faster I think he probably
runs like a four nine right and he's in
the football
wrestling football he likes to hit
people in a foot pain which is funny
because you meet cage he's the soft
spoken he's a Straight A Student
Government all the time the day I'm
sitting there and it's like his phone is
blowing I'm like dude what are you doing
he tested in the top 1.3 of the nation
for mathematics so he's sitting there
and all the other kids in the car I have
a lot of my kids private school the
whole time you know and so there all his
buddies are calling them up they're
helping he's tutoring Through Math to
the point where I'm like dude sorry I
don't know the cash app you're asking
yeah it's also like hey I'll answer
hopefully you've been paid for this
that's what I said I'm like dude like
you know what I mean like you you're at
school all day long you have football
practice until seven o'clock at night
like now it's time but he's just a great
kid which is weird because you sit there
he's the most loving like like people
sit there go he's a gentle giant but man
when he straps a helmet on that's what
he counts oh he like he tries to murder
people like kickoff season like I get
terrified because football scares the
[ __ ] out of me yeah I'm everybody oh
you're scared your daughter fights I'm
like no I'm terrified my boys play
football the whole time I'm just sitting
there I'm like oh please please please
like every kickoff I feel like I'm dying
I'm like oh please this cage is a
missile he's just trying to rip
someone's head off he just his goal in
life is to someone to leave on a
stretcher like that's what he just wants
to do he just wants to hit someone so
hard
that yeah you know all the coaches love
him because he just just wrecks people
when he hits him you know what I mean
and so so anyways so his freshman year
he he's up on varsity and they're like
look you're not going to get any playing
time kid you know I mean we're a top you
know National competitive team so you
can be on Varsity to say you're on
Varsity but you're going to get this
much playing time we'll put you down to
JV so that you can play the whole time
so he's on JV his freshman year you know
and at first he wasn't happy about that
but he got the play it's like hey look
next year as a sophomore you're going to
be the backup behind a kid who's like a
fight he still has a freshman he is a
phenomenal linebacker the kid that's
ahead of him I mean he like so then your
junior year you know you're going to
play some games when we play you know
home teams you'll start you know you're
always going to get in the second half
once we're up 70-0 you know what I mean
yeah and so like your junior year you're
gonna start and your senior year you'll
be one of the best linebackers in the
country I mean this is your project plan
yeah there's a plan all right cool buy
along so by putting my favorite stories
is we're sitting there at the uh the the
JV banquet right so football so sitting
there they're giving out the different
Awards I thought caves were going to get
the defensive player of the year award
and he didn't so I know he's
disappointed I'm disappointed so they
give out what's called the Gale Award
right and it's supposed to be like
basically like you know you and body so
they sit there go this kid if you were
to cut but him would bleed you know
orange and blue there are other colors
you know he's one of the most hardest
hitting this they're just saying all
these great things about this kid right
and they're like in fact the only down
part about him is if you see him after
practice if you don't have a half hour
don't let him catch your ass because
he's going to talk to you he's friendly
he's loving like you're like I'm like
sitting there and I'm like going man I
hope cage is friends with this kid man
like this kid's tits out this kid's an
awesome human man you know I mean like
cage like who's that kid make sure you
get his number like yeah you need to be
hanging out with that kid and it's like
the only freshman on the team to start
and then that's what I was like oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] so I grabbed my wife I'm like
babe I'm like trying to get my phone
because I'm like why didn't someone tell
me I would have recorded this you know
so I'm trying to grab my phone says what
are you doing like they're talking about
K and she goes they are I'm like yeah
only foreign
you want your kids to look at you as
Heroes but when your dad they kind of
take it for granted you know like Tony
Hawk was telling the story his kids in
the skateboarding and he said he comes
home and him and his friends are like
watching uh Professor skateboarders on
their iPad and they're like oh that this
move is whatever 360 or 180 and uh uh
Tony Hawk so he walks by he's like oh no
I uh he's like I actually uh created
that move that's a 360 like get out of
here he's like all right just went up
this room he's like they have no [ __ ]
game I get no respect man no respect so
sometimes you just Dad but I love it man
Kids Are Monsters uh yeah I'd be down to
go to Iowa wrestling yeah and then uh
when you guys compete on the card I'll
be there as a harbor Stadium dude your
Legend thank you brother one of my face
man I'm hours anytime you need anything
yeah we got to do this
hell yeah dude you're the best friend me
everybody if you're into thick boys
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one just kidding